jusqu'à aujourd'hui
cet autobus électrique seulement étaient
en opération à montréal desservant
depuis quatre ans l'alignement entre le
centre-ville et la station en grillant
dans l'ouest leur autonomie est très
limité et ils doivent être rechargés
après chaque parcours
cette façon de faire sera bientôt révolu
la société de transport de montréal
vient d'acquérir une trentaine d'autobus
électriques dernier cri ils sont testés
à partir d'ici dans l'immense centre de
transport stinson de l'arrondissement
saint-laurent 10 ont servi dans les rues
pour vous nos tests d'ingénierie mais
pas à dessein clientèle pascal renaud
dirige le projet d'électrification pour
la stm c'est un bus qui est silencieux
un bus qu'une belle douceur de roulement
ses débuts climatisés on met environ
trois heures pour la recharger ses
débuts ce qu'une autonomie d'environ 250
kilomètres donc on peut très bien la
signer sur des routes pointant m.de pm
pour faire les sorties du matin et les
sorties l'après-midi sans problème et
revenir au garage pour la recharge on ne
verra donc pas dans l'avenir une
multiplication des bornes de recharge
pour autobus dans les rues de montréal
les opérations se feront dans les
garages de la stm comme celui de stenson
parce qu'on a ici ces deux chargeurs 250
kilowatts qui permettent de recharger
nos bus 65 km de câbles fixés au plafond
transporte l'électricité jusqu'au 44
équipements de recharge du garage mais
si pour l'instant la capacité électrique
du centre stinson est suffisante elle ne
le sera plus dans les prochaines années
nous annonce donc le québec va acheter
pour cinq milliards 5 milliards
d'autobus urbains lors de la cop 26 en
écosse françois legault a annoncé son
intention
d'électrifier 55 % des autobus québécois
d'ici 2030 pour respecter cette cible la
stm qui n'a que 40 de bus électriques
aujourd'hui devrait donc en avoir 1072
dans huit ans c'est réaliste on est
confiant mais le défi colossal mené
confirme nos équipes travaillent fort
pour y arriver ce qui est important pour
nous c'est d'avoir un engagement ferme
de notre
dans le gouvernement donc de nos
partenaires qui vont permettre de
financer l'électrification déjà endetté
avec la pandémie la stm prévoit qu'il
faudra investir 4 milliards 700 millions
de dollars sur dix ans pour son
électrification la première phase de 670
millions est déjà en route et servir à
adapter quatre de ses neuf garage dont
celui de stinson ça va être de revoir
nos infrastructures pour amener la
puissance nécessaire pour recharger un
pack de 3 150 autobus installer les
équipements distribution installée les
chargeurs donc ça va demander des
travaux supplémentaires et des
agrandissements dans nos garages il
faudra aussi acheter les autobus les
nouveaux ont coûté un million deux cent
mille dollars chacun soit 400 milles de
plus qu'un autobus hybrides québec
s'engage à payer environ les deux tiers
de la facture d'électrification des
sociétés transport nos prochains bus
électrique qu'on va acheter c'est à
partir de 2025 donc on a programme de
remplacement qui va s'échelonner sur une
durée de seize ans on peut penser que si
en 2040 2041 qu'on voit remplacer le
parc complet de bus hybride diesel est
il faudra aussi former tout le personnel
dont les chauffeurs nous avons roulé
dans un des nouveaux autobus avec joseph
tame qui participent au projet pilote
depuis trois mois parce que c'est le fun
à conduire très fort c'est quelque chose
de nouveau c'est de la technologie on
sait quelque chose qu'on va pouvoir
travailler avec seiko logique
quand tous les chauffeurs comme joseph
rouleront électrique la stm estime que
112 mille tonnes de ges en moins seront
envoyées dans l'atmosphère chaque année
soit l'équivalent de retirer 28 mille
voitures à essence
[Musique]